[Music]
much like its title character snake eyes
gi joe origins is filled with mystery
impressive feats of martial artistry and
blurred lines of allegiance
with that in mind let's break down the
ending of snake eyes
aside from the word snake eyes somebody
wandering into this film
would have no idea it's a gi joe related
movie
for a good hour or so not that there's
anything wrong with that if you're in
the mood for 60 minutes of ninja
training and lengthy discussions about
fate revenge and loyalty
after that however the film seems to
diverge onto two paths
while the a story continues to be snake
eyes and tommy training and pledging
allegiance to the arashi kage clan
while battling the power-hungry kenta
the emerging bee story details a
decades-old gi joe
cobra conflict about to touch the lives
of both young ninjas
tommy fully emerges in the film's latter
third as the audience sees him
getting hold of his clan's precious
jewel intoxicated by the power it gives
and consumed by anger
he attempts to incinerate a fleeing
kenta later
that outburst is cited as the reason
tommy is ostracized from the clan
arashikage this sets up the film's
conclusion
as tommy and snake eyes officially
become enemies kenta is eliminated from
the equation and snake eyes finally has
enough closure
on the murder of his father to move on
with life
[Music]
you might want to grab a pen and paper
because there's a lot to keep track of
in the film's final moments from a
franchise building perspective
the audience has already seen scarlet
and the baroness form an unlikely
alliance to survive the carnage
in the urashikage temple as the smoke
clears varanes pulls a classic move by
sneaking away
just when the real fighting begins
scarlett on the other hand
rides things through to the bitter end
and then presents her new friend snake
eyes with a gift to celebrate his
apparent emancipation
she hands him a highly redacted folder
and name drops general joe colton
as die hard gi joe fans know colton is
also known as the original gi joe which
is a bit ironic since the name never
appeared in the classic 80s cartoon's
95 episodes portrayed by bruce willis in
retaliation
the character made a few appearances in
the gi joe a real american hero comic
series
and exists as an acknowledgement of the
60s kung fu grip line
that started it all the file reveals to
snake eyes that his father
died 20 years ago while serving as an
undercover joe
moments earlier the character learned
that the man who killed him was a
longtime cobra agent
so as this war seems to be launching a
new battlefront
snake eyes has plenty of motivation to
join in
tommy meanwhile has vanished from the
film at this point but give the credits
a few seconds to pass
and you'll see what the future has in
store for him as the screen lights back
up we see tommy on a plane only for the
baroness to make a surprise
appearance i came to make you enough for
tummy
[Music]
so as the credits roll we know that
cobra has been around for at least 20
years
the baroness has been a key cog for some
time
and now storm shadow is joining their
ranks
for a film ostensibly about two of the
greatest masked characters in 80s pop
culture
there's a startling lack of masks going
around until the end
both snake eyes and storm shadow see
their signature uniforms inch closer to
fruition
as the film progresses but we never see
them both fully masked and suited up to
fight each other
if you have a sharp eye you may have
noticed earlier when snake eyes
infiltrated the clan arashikage temple
that there was a glass laboratory which
housed among other things the snake eyes
mask
after kinta has been dispatched and the
arashi kage saved
snake eyes is finally presented with his
iconic mask
unfortunately his donning of the mask is
so brief that it's almost a head
scratcher but the film's final image
is full on snake eyes dressed as fans
remember
and prepared to head out on a mission
for the majority of the runtime of snake
eyes tommy and snake have
an on-again off-again blood brothers
friendship it's a precarious complicated
bond that has seen snake eyes save
tommy's life
tommy bring his new friend home and
invite him into his clan
snake eye is taking a mission for the
baroness but ultimately having her
recruit tommy
and the two of them having a final
falling out after tommy's expulsion from
the clan
now that kenta is out of the picture
storm shadow and snake eyes are poised
to carry on the battle that involved the
previous generation of gi joes and
cobras
in the film's closing moments we see
storm shadow fleeing
likely to the united states if the next
film is going to go full on gi joe
we also see snake eyes getting himself a
spiffy new mask
determined to set out after tommy
assuming snake eyes makes enough money
to warrant a green light for this latest
joe universe the next film would
undoubtedly have snake eyes in storm
shadow
now masked going toe to toe in a perfect
world this plotline would borrow heavily
from the classic 1984 comic issue
number 21 of gi joe a real american hero
entitled silent interlude told entirely
without a single speech bubble
sound effect or caption interlude has
remained a classic snake eyes story
decades later
and of course there's a murderer's row
of fan favorite cobra characters that
could make an appearance in a sequel
including cobra commander and destro not
to be outdone
there are probably twice as many joes
and the right casting and script could
make them
soar on the big screen so while the
snake eyes ending wraps up certain
elements of these origins
it also provides substantial hope for
the future of a beloved franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you